hi I'm Graham Michelle and you're  watching HP online Draya Michele strips  down to a sexy blue bikini for whom  hypnotic commercial et was exclusively  on set as she showed off her gorgeous  figure posing cliffside at a Los  angeles-area mansion Michele also  chatted with us about her wedding plans  saying after leaving reality TV she has  a better relationship with her fiance  Orlando Scandrick now we're talking  about him and his recovery and his  injury and you know other stuff planning  for their future I know you said you  were going to take about a year before  you guys got married but are you having  any plans right now for the wedding we  still don't have a date set yet and um  yeah I'm we're kind of just not really  in a rush for that week